how do you deal with impostor syndrome
from Philip Diddy you have mentioned
impostor syndrome a couple of times in
past podcasts I too suffer or struggle
from that despite some level of ability
to be successful in endeavors that I
feel an imposter in I'm grateful for
friends that mirror back to me my value
to them certainly you have recognized
that you have many fans and supporters
and even guess that you have had an
impact on it's a paradox for sure what
exactly does impostor syndrome look for
you how do you face and overcome it
enough to continue forward in your path
what would you tell someone trying to
flip the switch toward a desire to serve
humanity that is fraid of the next step
due to imposter syndrome yeah it's it's
a tough one because I'm always saying
that I suffer from impostor syndrome and
I think I do some extent I had this guy
Chris Evans came to my house who hosts
the most popular morning radio show in
the UK on Virgin Virgin Radio UK like
the breakfast show he's a fan of the
podcast what's up Chris if you listen to
I love you and he's always giving the
show shoutouts on morning radio and then
like London which is awesome
but he he he chant he came to my house
and we did a pot we did our own podcast
for his show and he's like you're always
saying you're an Impala you have
imposter syndrome you don't have
imposter syndrome he's like you know
what you're doing I'm like a do like I
don't know you know like I have to be
reminded and I think it's like a slow
boil thing like I I do feel like I can
own this space right now I've been doing
this for seven years I've interviewed
five hundred and twenty plus people
I'm confident when I sit here that I
know what I'm doing that I'm gonna be
able to get through an hour and a half
and it's gonna be you know they're not
all gonna be amazing but hopefully you
know all of them have some value so
that's a story that I have to some
extent transcended back to that other
question I like to throw it around
though every once in a while because I
you know I it is like we're it why do
you have those pinch-me moments where
I'm like what am i doing in Jack
Dorsey's house right now how did this
happen you know do I have any
qualifications to talk to this guy like
or
some you know incredible athlete that I
revere you know it's it's I think it's
more of a it's more of a humility at
this point and Chase Jarvis photographer
without on the podcast who has a lot of
wisdom on the creative process says you
know you you you know you hear that
phrase like fake it till you make it
he's like make it till you make it just
keep making it you know like inch your
way forward like this podcast didn't
start in this beautiful set no no it you
grow into these things over time and
with that I think you slowly as you
develop some level of mastery over what
you're doing you're able to kind of
transcend that idea of being an imposter
I would say that I have a deep-seated
insecurity in me that is you know I've
spent a lifetime trying to unpack and
overcome but it crops his head up once
in awhile and tells me like I have no
business being here and somebody else
should be sitting here and when are they
gonna when's the guy gonna walk in here
and take away my you know like sorry
who told you you're out cash your pod
Kahoot wants to hear what you have to
say or your opinion on any of this you
know the real rich role is just that you
all of the imposter syndrome definitely
is creeping up around this new format
because this is new right it's like
there are people there are political
pundits you know a lot more about this
stuff than I do let's let them do that
but I have to make it until I make it
right you know and the more I can do
that the less the less like held hostage
I am by that insecurity in that sense
that I am an imposter so how do you
drill that down into some kind of
tangible advice for Philip
it really is make it till you make it
right like if you're feeling like you're
an impostor
don't give that story power like act as
if like acting contravention a lot like
do ya take in in in in a there's a
phrase take contrary action mmm-hmm so
just because your brain is telling you
something doesn't mean that it's true
right your instinct is broken often when
it comes to things like this so when you
take the contrary what would somebody
who didn't have impostor syndrome do
well they would make another podcast or
they would paint a painting or they
would like get up on stage at the Comedy
Store or whatever it is right get out of
your comfort zone make it till you make
it and take the contrary action I like
it to me I'm thinking don't believe
everything you feel and write and but I
think the impostor syndrome there is a
positive to it not a not the syndrome
but there's a positive to the fact that
you're not comfortable there's something
to be said for not getting comfortable
and knowing that you have to show up and
actually do the work you can't just turn
on the mics and expect it to work you
can't just like show up and and put put
take you know get a story done have you
haven't done the research for this story
yeah it goes back to humility the the
the healthy second cousin of imposter
syndrome is humility that's it writes
like rather than say I don't deserve to
be here just say look I have a lot to
learn I'm still going to show up get out
of my comfort zone and do this thing but
I appreciate that I'm just starting and
I'm not going to be perfect but I'm
gonna do it anyway like to have that
courage to to do it in perfectly right I
felt like I felt like I was an impostor
for the first seven years I was a
journalist you know and even even 10 13
years deep I still wondered if I could
do it right and and I've been doing it
for 13 years who's gonna take that
little hat off your head with the press
thing right right and now now I don't
feel that way anymore
but I still every time I have a new
project to do
I still wonder can I do it but not in a
negative way I have this muscle because
you've done it so many times like as a
writer when you're beginning that
project you're like how am I ever gonna
figure out how to do this like it just
seems hopeless right but you've been in
that situation so many times that you're
like I know I feel this way right now
but I also know like I always figure it
out that's right it always ends up
better you know you just do enough
drafts it'll get good
[Laughter]
[Music]